my brother actually taught me how to
masturbate and uh we're best of friends
man
i think i was like
11 we shared a room and he uh
he was awake and woke me up and he's
messing around and i'm like yo tony what
are you doing
he looked at me man he said i'm
masturbating it feels so good you've
never masturbated damn tony huh
homer
[Music]
i don't even know what that is man
so right next to him he sat me down
he taught me and being 11 man with those
boners i couldn't get enough of it i was
going into school
i was like i'd sneeze and i'd crack a
boner i can't believe riley doesn't
bradley doesn't he's got to be walking
around full tilt baby
yeah i mean look riley mal's a
homeschooled kid and who knows what
happened no and who knows what god wants
for him or if his parents are
you know trying to detour them off of
god's bust path i don't know
you know this is fascinating to me that
your brother
it is fascinating to me that your
brother taught you how to masturbate i'd
never
i've never heard of that
um
and at first i'm thinking man this guy's
this is this is
this is not good
but then the more i'm thinking about it
i'm like this is
this is
maybe this is how it's supposed to be
you know
because otherwise who teaches you
you know some creep over there or some
guy selling sugar syrup or whatever
you know some guys got you in his truck
or something he's a trucker he drove off
the interstate he's putting tootsie
rolls in you and michael grutsch's mouth
and now he you know
and now y'all all dampened up over there
y'all you know and you don't even know
anybody
maybe it's the brother's responsibility
maybe it's the brother's responsibility
or the father's responsibility
that's a great i wonder how they used to
do it in native culture
because that's where we're missed we're
missing all of literally all of these
beats you know like we're missing this
connective tissue that
we allow everything to be made taboo and
then
we
and then it's profited off of products
are created it's like
if my brother taught me how to
masturbate i
i use the same style as him you know
it's like people would know us by our
style if you know say a cop saw somebody
jerking off near a building and they
just see the shadow they could
oh that's that you know that's how their
fa that's the family
style you know i mean i just
that's fascinating
man you know i i think a good response
on this what do you guys think
985-664-9503
is it a brother is that a good idea it's
a brother's responsibility
to teach their younger sibling
how to masturbate
the father might not be because that's
but i don't know
yeah i don't it's not
you don't
do it to him but you
i don't know have somebody's father
taught them i don't know some of this is
just really interesting to me man
you know i learned from a magazine and
then i found a dirty movie and i put
that [ __ ] in and next thing you know
i'd ejaculated and i felt horrible i
didn't know what was going on
and i felt ashamed there was nobody i
could ask my dad couldn't even hear me
i remember he was 82 or 83
and i tried to ask him something and his
[ __ ] heart pressure went up and he
all he couldn't drive his car
and i remember he pulled the car over
and i thought he was so sad that i'd
asked him
and it had nothing to do with it he was
just senior citizen and just
had decided he couldn't drive anymore
and i'm just sitting there and
i just i don't know just a lot of bad
[ __ ] but um
anyway his brother taught him there you
go that's one way to do it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one